heute bestellen wir gleich drei meiner
Lieblingsgerichte Pizza Burger und einen
gesunden Salat aber es gibt einen
kleinen Haken und zwar werde ich alles
was ich bestelle mit jeglichen
verfügbaren Extras bestellen das heißt
wenn wir Pech haben kriegen wir gleich
ein Burger mit fünf Patties 10 kg
schampigns und was weiß ich was bei der
Pizza wird's ganz verrückt Beil Pizzen
kann man ja auch beliebig pimpen und
beim Salat sage ich Euch so viel denkt
nicht dass das weniger interessant wird
weil wir haben einen Laden bei dem wir
bestellen werden das wird crazy fangen
wir direkt an mit dem ersten Laden wir
nehmen food Brother denn ich glaube da
gibt es einige Extras die wir auswählen
können erstmal die Grundlage mit welchem
Burger wollen wir denn starten ich nehme
in der Regel eigentlich den bber Burger
zweimal cheese zweimal beef Salat
Tomaten Zwiebel Mayo Ketchup wir nehmen
den als Grundlage und jetzt wird's
richtig spannt was können wir alles noch
da drauf hauen aber ich frage mich auch
wie wir das Verpacken wollen denn auf
unseren bber Burger kommt jetzt erstmal
extra beef dann extra chicken cheese
Bacon Jalapenos Nachos Guacamole undten
extra
Brötchen ich weiß auch nicht genau wie
das funktionieren soll dann sind wir für
einen Burger im Menü bei
37,20 € und ich glaube der Burger der
gleich kommt wird wahrscheinlich so groß
sein deshalb bleiben wir gespannt und
bestellen der Zwischenzeit beim nächsten
Restaurant bevor wir zum Highlight
kommen was unweigerlich die Pizza ist
bestellen wir jetzt einmal den Salat da
bestellen wir bei einem Laden den ich
schon mal getestet habe als er ganz neu
eröffnet hat hier in Köln stadtsalat die
sind an und für sich schon relativ teuer
aber auch mega nice ich glaube ich
bleibe bei meinem Klassiker oder
haveland beef halt auch geil haveland
beef schon soll ich hast du Bock ja komm
dann bestellen wir die haveland beef
einmal und jetzt wird's wild da steht
sogar haveland beef absell also quasi
wie können sie uns mehr verkaufen nehmen
wir doch einfach mal alles wir sind mit
einem Salat bei
44,95 € oh das tut
weh Augen zu und Karte durch wir
bestellen beim dritten
Restaurant V
bestellter
also ja
bittees einfach mal ausprobieren einfach
mal was Verrücktes
machenes alles auf einen
Burger
jaeres
alles sei kreativ einfach du machst das
schon
ich bin ich bin gespannt was ankommt wie
abgeft kann man sein schauen wir einfach
mal welchen laden wir nehmen Ken ich gar
nicht happy Slice W auch interessant ne
aber ich glaub die haben nicht viele ext
ich hätte gerne einf ich mal die haben
keine Marita ja gestalte deine eigene
okay weiß was da steht was denn wähle
deine Extras wähle bis zu 40 das
krank rein gerade das ist krank soll ich
ein machen mach mal bitte
67,60 € für eine 26 cm Pizza das ist
wirklich so bescheuert Alter weißt du
aber das ist eigentlich genau das worum
es in diesem Video geht das würde
niemand machen genau und was kommt an
die Frage beantworten wir und ich
bestell das Ding jetzt einfach Käserand
nehmen wir auch noch und die besondere
Anweisung bitte wirklich alles drauf
machen mir das wird verrückt die erste
Bestellung ist da und wie sagt man so
schön die en werden die ersten sein die
Pizza ist als allererstes angekommen und
ich sage euch so viel dieser Karton
wiegt verdammt viel und auf jeden Fall
mehr als ein klassischer Pizzakarton
wiegt denn hier drin ist einfach mal
alles die teuerste Bestellung 70 € und
ich bin wirklich gespannt wie das jetzt
aussieht seid ihr
ready wow alter Schwede das sieht halt
aus wie ein Kuchen und nicht wie eine
Pizza der Boote hat auch ziemlich lange
vorm Laden gewartet ich könnte mir
vorstellen das liegt daran dass das
einfach viel länger backt wenn es halt
so ist wie es ist aber ich hole erstmal
ein Messer und dann schneiden wir das
gute Stück
auf diese einzelnen Stücke sind wirklich
einfach straight Kuchenstücke ja Freunde
man erkennt hier perfekt hier ist
wirklich von allem etwas drauf schauen
wir einfach mal kperern chicken
Basilikum natürlich Käse schwarze Oliven
ein bisschen jalapenno Gurke glaube ich
da unten Rucola es ist wirklich von
allem etwas dabei auf der anderen Seite
haben wir ein bisschen Mais ein bisschen
Salami gekochtes Ei und ich glaube das
ist wirklich eine Pizza die ich so
schnell nicht mehr vergessen werde ob es
jetzt schmeckt schauen wir mal ich
probiere gibt's da überhaupt noch
Teig
boah also ein steht fest die Sachen die
geschmacklich intensiv sind dominieren
wir haben hier ein bisschen sadelle und
die sadelle überlagert einfach mal alles
also du schmeckst wirklich nur so dieses
salzige fischige von der sadelle ich
muss noch mal ein weiteren bisschen
nehmen ich weiß nicht ob der der Hunger
ist ne aber es geht echt klar ja ich bin
irgendwie auch so ein bisschen so ein
Allesesser habe ich das Gefühl aber es
ist irgendwie voll in Ordnung schmeckt
gar nicht schlecht fin auch krass dass
keiner nachgefragt hat ob irgendwie bei
mir alles in Ordnung ist einfach gemacht
aber ohne Witz Leute es funktioniert
überraschend gut auch unser Salat ist
angekommen und der Burger braucht
einfach wirklich Ewigkeiten aber wir
lassen uns den Tag nicht vermiesen
sondern gucken mal was wir hier feines
bekommen haben erstmal zwei für eins
Gutschein und ich habe es mir schon fast
gedacht eine zweite Schüssel so
ansonsten haben wir hier noch
wahrscheinlich Schwarzbrot und Schabat
unser Dressing aber das fühlt sich nicht
ganz nach 45 € an wenn ich ehrlich bin
schauen wir mal rein wie es aussieht das
ist die habeland beef bow okay die füse
die haben uns einfach die ganz normale
Bowl gemacht also ich glaube das ist sie
ein zu ein so wie sie steht für 1690 ne
ST ist auch einfach was teurer aber hier
drüben müsste dann einfach alles sein
was wir an Extras bestellt haben schauen
wir rein und ja Alter alles drin was wir
bestellt haben extra roast beef extra
feterkäse eine burata eine Avocado die
beiden verschiedenen Soßen Süßkartoffel
einfach alles ich muss sagen das sieht
auf jeden Fall deutlich appetitlicher
aus als unsere Pizza die wir gerade eben
hatten und im Prinzip haben die schlau
gemacht weil jetzt kann man einfach das
Essen da nebenbei so ein bisschen
snacken also will ich mich nicht
beklagen hier chwat hier ist unser C
Dressing das ist alles was wir bekommen
für 45 € so Leute dann probieren wir mal
unseren 4 € Salat oder unsere 45 € Bowl
ich bin ehrlich gesagt fast sicher dass
das lecker schmeckt und ich bin auch
froh dass es ein Salat ist und nicht
wieder alles durcheinander geworfen weil
nachdem gerade eben mein Magen wird auf
eine belastprobe gestellt mein Magen
braucht erstmal ein Espresso wir bra
erst Espresso wieder
klarzukommen der Burger ist gerade
angekommen und ich habe ein bisschen
Angst ist schwer
ja aber warm sehr gut siehst mal also
stadtsalat so wie ich es kenne ist auch
einfach es fühlt sich immer so fresh an
und auch so ein bisschen gesund so ein
bisschen gesund ist glaube ich auch das
richtige Stichwort weil das sind gute
Zutaten keine Frage aber kalorienarm ist
es nicht also alles hier ran ist super
lecker macht es Sinn das alles auf
einmal zu bestellen auf gar keinen Fall
macht das Sinn dafür 45 € auszugeben
hier ist das gute Stück wir mussten zwar
ein bisschen drauf warten aber sie haben
sich auch sehr lieb darum gekümmert
deshalb Kreiden wir das mal nicht an
aber hier drin ist ein burgermenü das
insgesamt 37 € kostet deshalb bin ich
gespannt die Tüte verspricht best Burger
in town bin gespannt ob der auch in der
37 € Variante noch der best Burger in
Town ist weil ansonsten bestelle ich
sehr gerne bei food Brother und
überzeugen auch häufig sehr und das hier
überrascht mich jetzt wir haben eine
einfache burgerbox wir haben die das den
hinbekommen vor allem da ist ja auch ein
extra Ban drin wahrscheinlich haben wir
jetzt einfach so ein komplett
zusammengequetschten okay Burger darin
da drin haben wir sonst nur noch Pommes
und die Soße gucken wir jetzt einfach
mal gemeinsam rein was uns hier erwartet
der Baba Burger mit allen
Extras es sind wirklich vier BNS wie
haben die das denn geschafft Alter ist
das Ding schwer oh mein Gott für den Job
den wir den gegeben haben sieht das
verdammt gut aus oder bis jetzt die
beste Ausführung kurz ein blockbrett zum
Schneiden geholt jetzt schneiden wir
einfach mal in der Mitte auf um zu
überprüfen ob wirklich alles drin ist
was drin sein soll guck dir das mal an
von hin das ist das ist krass die haben
einfach einen Burger in denen Burger
gepackt und es funktioniert und es sieht
gut aus ja also sieht gut aus ist
relativst du wir haben angerufen um
wirklich sicherzustellen dass wir das so
haben wollen und dann haben die die
Aufgabe einfach richtig geil erfüllt
kurz mich ein bisschen so fühlen lassen
als sei ich komplett gestört jetzt
Freunde gucken wir einmal was sich
wirklich drin befindet ich glaube der
Burger wiegt so 5 600 g und von innen
sieht der so aus alter Schwede beef
chicken beef beef dann haben wir noch
Bacon wir haben Jalapenos wir haben
wirklich alles was ich darauf befinden
sollin noch mal burgerbann und dadurch
dass das so ein briocheban ist das
verschwindet und wird so klein dass es
tatsächlich funktioniert jetzt werde ich
glaube ich die krasseste Maulsperre ever
kriegen wenn ich da jetzt reinbeißen
möchte aber wofür hat man eine große
fresse ich
[Musik]
probiere ich kann Loki wirklich
vorstellen dass er nicht mal scheiße ist
also der Carsten hen der
Restaurantkritiker hat uns ein einen
Begriff beigebracht der uns seitdem
begleitet eatability wie gut kann man
etwas essen das ist glaube ich eine
glatte Sex weil du saust dich sowas von
ein ab und kriegst einfach auch deinen
Mund nicht so weit auf also ich habe es
gerade fast geschafft Prob noch
mal aber das aber schon sehr sehr gut
wie du das machst Bo die Nachos die
Käsesoße Chili da sind halt keine zwei
Zutaten dabei die nicht zueinander
passen auf die falscheste Art und Weise
ist das irgendwie richtig so das ist
halt einfach der Inbegriff von so einem
X XL Burger wenn ich alles bewerten
müsste Preisleistung inbegriffen oder
außen vor außen vor okay nur der
Geschmack nur der Geschmack gebe ich der
Pizza eine dre von ze weil es war halt
nicht lecker es war es war nur nicht
eklig so kann man sagen stadtsalat lowy
so eine ainhb von ze ja halt ein
normaler stadsalat gr genau die haben
ein bisschen Thema verfehlt weil Sie uns
einfach die SES extra gegeben haben und
dieser Burger hier der schmeckt schon
lecker Alter aber er ist auch nicht
besser als ein normaler Burger so so ist
nicht wenn der normale food Brother
Burger als lieferburger so eine un von
ze ist würde ich sagen ist das hier es
ist schon eine acht weil es schmeckt
echt gut und du hast einfach alles drauf
was geiles und es passt auch alles gut
zusammen Freunde ich glaube ich probiere
gerade irgendwie Sinn zu finden in der
Sache in der es keinen Sinn gibt der
einzige Sinn war dass ihr unterhalten
werdet und ich hoffe das wurdet ihr ich
habe mal wieder eine Sache bestellt und
Sachen gegessen von denen ich niemals
gedacht hätte dass ich es tun würde
falls es euch unterhalten hat lasst
gerne ein Like da oder ein Abo dieser
Burger hier freut sich gerade darauf
gegessen zu werden das machen wir jetzt
und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Video
wieder bis dahin ciao
ciao